6 25 on your monday morning we have more
on the cone maze on las vegas boulevard
that may be driving you crazy the bottom
line if you haven't gotten used to it
yet you'll have plenty of chances to do
so
after clark county confirmed that there
will be ongoing repaving related lane
restrictions through july from sahara
south to spring mountain i got an update
from the city of las vegas on the
boulevard from sahara north up to stuart
so that three year long 125 million
dollar project
well they say it's moving right along
and by the time this biggest project in
the public works department's history is
done
there will be brand new underground
water sewer storm drain gas and fiber
optics utilities
by the way the existing drains they're
from 1954
water lines from 1955. some of the
traffic signals from 1965 and
the sewer pipe was installed 79 years
ago in 1942
there will be all new traffic signals
and medians replanting existing trees
adding 200 more
new curbs gutters sidewalks new and
improved bus stop access with two new
right turn pockets on the boulevard at
charleston
and at stuart now the work is going to
be scheduled from 6 am to 4 pm monday
through friday
the city says yes get used to those lane
restrictions they recommend maryland
parkway or grand central for north-south
alternatives
please buckle up drive carefully and put
down that phone if there's something
driving you crazy you can email me
traffic 8
8newsnow.com